Hydra McCoy here project lead at respawn
entertainment here to answer some of
your questions with Wired's apex support
[Music]
alright let's get into it
first question is from well played think
that's a play on the words of well
played
what are your pro tips for apex a lot of
times I feel like I made the right moves
and I'm still one step or one shot
behind how do I get to that next level
with a gif of caustic the toxic trapper
honestly it's about time played as well
as thinking ahead you say you think you
make the right moves and then you're
still one step or one shot behind you
have to be able to anticipate you know
the map know your character know your
teammates characters know your weapons
and be thinking ahead strategize don't
just mash ready up for the next match
think about how your previous match went
and what you could do better on the next
one but as your parents always told you
in piano lessons practice makes perfect
so keep at it from the Knights Templar
at Tanner Webster
he asks at play apex so I play on ps4
but I got a cast today any tips you know
I'm looking at your cast they're the
Knights Templar and I'm not seeing any
reason to having excuses for subpar
performance both of your index and
middle finger or fully-operational as is
your thumb so you can operate both r1
and r2 and the right thumbstick and all
the face buttons so get out there and
get some of those wins please next up we
have its Wolfer wrath at yo boy wolf RF
that's a really good name
wait what's an heirloom and how do you
get one of those so an heirloom is an
incredibly rare set of drops you can get
out an apex pack it's a less than 1%
drop rate so that's very rare currently
it is a set of items for Wraith I bet if
you looked it up on YouTube you'd find
numerous videos they're not gameplay
enhancing it is purely cosmetic to show
off how baller you are to your friends
hope you get one next we have a question
from rose / mrs. rose War V so the real
question for playing packs is what is
bloodhounds bird named this might be a
world's first I have been informed that
bloodhounds bird has a proper name of
Arthur Olivia at Olivia slays what kind
of stats are considered good for apex
I'm still lost on how to rate how I'm
doing well honestly the stat that
matters most is how full your heart is
whenever you revive a teammate this is a
team game
it's about being friendly
it's about sharing so if you're getting
fulfilment from that I think you're
doing just fine
who's the best character in Apex legends
the real answer is there is no such
thing as the best character they're all
my favorite children but honestly
lifeline is my favorite and my best
she has would I consider be the most
powerful ability with the care package
because I love boot Scholl Vic's at Big
Mac 7:06 one is asking remember him feel
old yet you know what that's not half
bad I like that name and yes I feel old
we have a question from guzik's says hey
can we have replay mode so we can play
around with camera angles and create
contacts hashtag apex legends at play
apex at respawn unfortunately we do not
have any comment for future features or
content in the game right now but if you
stay tuned we have a lot more coming to
apex legends I wish I could tell you
more at C DEP see yo at play apex I made
hashtag bloodhound if she revealed her
identity what do you think am I actually
close we specifically have made
bloodhound a very mysterious character
so much so that I don't even know what
bloodhound looks like under all that
year so your guess right now is as good
as mine j7z with a little airplane emoji
honest question do we think apex has a
good chance of having a big compazine
those video no comp means competition
aka eSports so we have a lot of players
who are really into apex Legends right
now and they are absolutely stunning at
the game we have a desire for players to
play our game at such high levels but
currently we don't have any plans to
announce for any competitive scene but
we definitely do keep our eyes on what
people are doing and what they're asking
about tal talent cough , at respawn
please CC @ DK o''h 5 that's me and it's
a reddit thread and it's a suggestion
when you kill the last person in the
game make it so they don't die but
instead go to a downed state so we can
use our finisher move to win the game
that sounds like a pretty good idea to
humiliate your enemies like I know that
next is a question from its red Jedi
time to give at play apex ago let's see
what all the fuss is about any tips
question mark
hashtag apex legends battle royale and a
screenshot of him on a Playstation 4 yes
tips for new players finish the tutorial
teach a lot about how to use the
system and some other the abilities of
the game and more importantly once
you're in the game use that ping system
it lets you communicate quickly with
teammates find loot share loot and just
overall have a really fun time at Kyle
vetto vely question is how many apex
packs you have to open in order to have
every item in the game
hashtag apex led gens with a D in there
cool the answer is I don't actually know
because we are constantly adding more
stuff to the game currently I believe we
have over 1,900 items in the apex packs
so you can do some math but we also have
crafting currency in there with the
crafting metal so honestly just open
what you want and keep playing the game
having fun and showing off to your
friends and I'll we'll be right in the
world
have fun next up Pawnee high fashion is
is this a record at play apex my new
lowest time 10 minutes face that's
pretty dang impressive I haven't checked
out any stats lately but I would not be
surprised if that's near the top so you
probably want to secure your place and
keep going even faster next question
comes from Nexus question are we gonna
see leaderboards in the future I can't
keep track of how many wins I have you
know that's a pretty non subtle humble
brag there they have so many wins you
can't hold them all some of us are out
there slumming it with single-digit wins
so just keep that in mind
leaderboards have definitely been asked
for a lot as well as additional stat
tracking you can keep requesting
features and things you would like to
see in the game and we are definitely
listening just keep talking to us and
we're gonna keep working on the game and
adding stuff that hopefully you really
enjoy next up is a question from Dennis
do that at play apex asking the hard
questions
why does lifeline how a drumstick in her
first finisher doesn't seem to fit her
character is it not a drumstick no it
absolutely is a drumstick and lifeline
loves music actually if you watch her a
run when she doesn't have a weapon she's
just kind of jamming along like she's
playing drums already so she's got a
constant beat in her head and she's just
trying to share that love of music with
her enemies next one comes from true
agitator at respawn is cross console
going to happen question mark we don't
want to comment on specificities of
future features or content right now but
I can say that cross play something we
really care about and we are looking
into cuz we know that people have
friends on all sorts of platforms and
you really want to go to the arena and
get some wins together so stay tuned
next up we have a question from kool-aid
man so my question is why is lifeline
dual wielding pistols question
question mark question mark those aren't
actually pistols what he is referring to
here is one of lifelines banner poses
where she has actually holding two of
the syringe models and wielding them as
if they were cool revolvers and she was
a cowboy from the 1800s next is a
question from Kaz at play apex question
:
does the win with full squad tracker
only count wins when entire squad is
alive or is it total wins with that
legend because of its total wins when
it's about and not counting properly I
believe it is total wins with an entire
squad still alive when you get the win
there is a separate statue for wins with
a particular legend hopefully I've
clarified that if not well you might
have a bug please report it damian watts
at damian watts eight at play apex is
this going to be on switch anytime soon
if so when is the release date if the
switch was coming we would tell you and
we would blast it across the world we
are hearing all the switch players who
say they want the game I can't make any
promises right now we have a lot of
things that we're working on so stay
tuned for anything future but currently
we don't have anything to announce next
up we have Tito the boss at play apex
are there any plans for a new map I
think a city based one or snow one would
be sick currently we have not announced
any plans for a new map but I agree with
you snow maps are always awesome and my
favorite map from our previous games
titanfall in titanfall 2 was Angel City
so I think you and I we got this we know
exactly what's good so thanks for the
note next up we have a question from
Evan B Wilker at play apex just found
this little puppy in the training map
any comment question mark emoji with no
mouth and I'm thinking emoji yes that is
a little Corgi we have very talented and
loving of their pets designers and
artists here at respawn and they tend to
pepper all sorts of great little Easter
eggs around our games I'm glad you found
that one but there's a lot more to find
so keep looking alright next comes to us
from apex legends Intel question time
what kind of scenery would you like to
see in future apex legends Maps I would
personally love a snow themed one I love
hearing all of your thoughts in the game
which chat and replies hashtag apex
legends so this seems like we have a
theme here of people wanting snow maps
interesting again we haven't commented
on any future map plans but we love
hearing you guys's suggestions we know
that you guys are playing a game a lot
and you have really strong feelings so
please share those feelings with us we
want to
Thanks next message comes from at rat
patootie haha rat patootie got it can we
talk about how affects Legends has to
lgbtq+ characters Gibraltar is gay and
blood hound is non-binary props to that
respawn for making progress in the
gaming industry we need to see more of
this hand-clapping emoji yes yes true
Gibraltar is gay and blood hound is
non-binary and we think diversity is
incredibly important not just in games
but in the world to be aware of everyone
we're all humans and we all feel things
for people and that's great so when we
started out on apex legends we knew we
wanted to have a cast that was as
diverse as the people who play it we're
really excited by the response we've
gotten it's been really positive and you
can expect more of that from us in the
future so thanks for playing and now
we're delving into some YouTube comments
first up Emiliano s would like to know
which is better our 301 or Prowler with
select-fire personally I'm in love with
a prowler especially with a select-fire
it does a ton of damage it's pretty
accurate especially if you got some
attachments on it and also just love the
way the gun sounds it feels really good
and meaty both can be very first tool in
almost any situation slight upside to
the our 301 you can change this rate of
fire to single-shot so if you're trying
to get a little bit longer range it's
gonna be easier with 301 than with a
prowler either a select-fire or not so
what pro tip for you there nas on
YouTube would like to know can you shoot
while sliding on the hills and the
answer is a resounding yes it's one of
my favourite things to do I love sliding
down a hill and revealing an enemy who
is behind cover and taking them out like
I'm some awesome rock star with a gun
instead of a guitar I know it's weird
but I like it
Channel 3 2 2 4 3 9 to would like to
know his two wins for level 5 without
playing with friends good anytime you
get a win is a good day I don't care if
it's with friends or not keep at it
have fun Scott Adkins this question is
has anyone noticed when respawning a
down player badge or sometimes be an
option to quote hide player badge quote
does anyone know what the that
means
yes so that means your spectating
through the eyes of another player on
your team and we put the banner card up
on the screen so you can see how awesome
they are and how many cool things
they've unlocked for their banner cards
but if you don't want to see that stuff
you just want to see the game we let you
hide it singing in full view of what
your teammate is doing another question
on YouTube from I am just a random
person I
we're all just random people so welcome
question do you need a backpack in this
game like pub G please please please no
I hate them edit another Q arthur gun
rareness like format green blue epic but
for this like levels or something or is
it just guns but all the same type do
the same damage so question one you do
not need a backpack
it is highly advantageous to have a
backpack because it means you can carry
more ammo more meds more ordnance all
sorts of things so if you see a backpack
please pick it up or ping it for a buddy
so they can pick it up themself and the
second question about rarity of weapons
no all weapons do the same damage every
time you pick up in our 301 it's going
to do the damage of an AR 301 we do have
some gold tier weapons scattered around
the map where they have attachments on
them and you cannot take them off so
it's like a fully kitted weapon so it
has a barrel and a stock and a optics on
it already but they don't necessarily do
more damage they're just one that has
been fully kitted up star co is asking
how do I enable the grenade trajectory
the grenade trajectory is talking about
is this arc that shows you where your
grenades gonna land and if you just
press and hold the trigger it'll draw
that line so you know we're gonna it's
gonna land and then we let go
follows the dark pretty cool next is a
question from dark blade what's that
thing you can revive yourself with so we
have a couple of legendary tier items
that you can pick up throughout a match
whether that's a backpack a shield or a
down shield and I believe it's the down
shield that lets you self revive when
you're not there's been some really
funny videos of enemy teams in the final
circle of a match not realizing that the
enemy they just knocked is self reviving
themselves to come back and wipe out an
entire squad for a win it's great fun
are everyone that wraps it up for apex
support with Wired I really appreciate
all the questions we love how much you
guys are playing the game and loving it
and keep sending your questions along we
love hearing from you guys thanks a lot